hello everyone welcome to cfar's series
of virtual talks on science has the exit
strategy
if you're not familiar with us cfar is a
canadian-based global research
organization that convenes extraordinary
minds from around the world to address
some of the most important questions
facing science and humanity
my name is kate getty i am a senior
director of research at seafar
and it is my pleasure to host today's
talk the sick and the healthy
how can we help each other on the state
of wrath of the state of excuse me
rapidly evolving research into the
treatment and protection of covid19
patients
in particular we'll explore the very hot
topics of the use of convalescent plasma
and international vaccine developments
for today's talk i'm delighted to
introduce our two speakers
alan bernstein and arturo cassidvall
starting with alan allen is president
and ceo
of cfar in addition to this role since
may he has served on canada's covid19
vaccine task force
providing advice to the federal
government on its vaccine development
and procurement strategy
he served previously as executive
director of the global hiv and vaccine
enterprise
in new york and was the inaugural
president of the canadian institutes of
health research
he is a now much sought-after science
advisor in countries around the world
and we're particularly grateful to have
him at the helm of cfar at a time like
this
arturo is a bloomberg distinguished
professor of molecular microbiology and
immunology
and infectious diseases at the johns
hopkins bloomberg school of public
health
and johns hopkins school of medicine and
he is a world-renowned expert in
infectious
disease research arturo's connection to
cfar
is that he is the advisory committee
chair of seafarer's fungal kingdom
threats and opportunities research
program
but of interest for today's talk he has
also been one of the key individuals
involved in establishing and chairing
the u.s national covit 19 convalescent
plasma project
before we dive in i'll quickly set the
parameters
today's session will last 45 minutes
i will take advantage of being host to
start the conversation but then we'll
hand it over to alan and arturo for a
more free flowing discussion
for the online participants joining us
if you have questions for either alan or
otero
please submit it through the q a
function at the bottom of your screen
and i'll find time in the last 10 to 15
minutes to pose your questions to the
speakers
lastly i'll mention that this session is
being recorded and will be available on
the c4 website next week
so to kick it off i'll start with a
question for you
arturo there has been huge media and
public interest in the potential of
using plasma
from survivors of covid19 as treatment
for those who are sick
with yesterday's news that top u.s
health officials overturned
the fda's intention to issue emergency
authorization for this treatment
but before we get there or maybe let's
take a step back
with a brief history of the use of
convalescent plasma
so can you tell us what is plasma how
long have we been using it to treat the
sick
and what led you to believe it could be
useful in in treating covid19
thank you katie the definition of plasma
is simple uh
you all have plasma it is the liquid
part of your blood
uh in the past the way that the liquid
was obtained was they would take your
blood out and they let it
clog and then they spun down the clot
that is known as serum
that's why in history you use words like
serum therapy
and all that today we have machines that
can collect this liquid
uh by plasmaphrases and
um and it now is called plasma and now
it has all the components it's not
clotted or anything like that
and the difference between convolution
plasma and plasma
is only if the complex and plasma comes
from somebody who's recovered
from coping and it would have in their
blood
antibodies to uh to the virus
so in terms of usage it was first usage
at the turn of the 20th century it's
been used
uh for 120 years uh there is a
tremendous amount of experience with
this
it's being used in practically every
epidemic including the 1918 epidemic to
the recent ebola
epidemic in africa advantages are that
is relatively low tech all you need is
to have a transformation facility and
people who recover
and you can then generate it
anywhere it's one of the issues
historically has been that it's often
used emergently
and therefore hasn't been put through
the kind of rigorous randomized clinical
trials that you like to see with new
medicines
uh so it's a storied history and the
reason that i got involved with this was
because i knew the history
and i knew that it could be very rapidly
deployed and in the united states
we went from not using it to using it in
a month and
close to 70 or 80 000 people have been
treated
already so el arturo maybe i'll maybe
i'll jump in here
um first of all i've been really looking
forward to this conversation for
weeks now uh a chance to have a chat
with you about
uh two really important topics uh the
convalescent plasma and vaccines has
been
you know top of mind for a lot of people
and so you're the guy
for convalescent plastic so i've been
looking forward to hearing your views
about this
um so tell us maybe catch us up on what
do we what's been done so
far both in terms of your own efforts uh
the efforts coming out of the mayo
clinic
uh and elsewhere perhaps other countries
uh and
what what's the data uh for uh covet 19
or cyrus kobe 2.
right so um i would put that the first
ones to use it was the chinese
it was used in china first and they
began to provide reports
by the spring the italians have used it
and what we did here in the united
states was that we organized
it was completely grassroots movements
by doctor scientists
we formed a a group that developed the
protocols
and then as a result of the historical
strength
and the likelihood that it'd be safe uh
the
foreign drug administration allowed the
use of plasma
and the use of plasma has taken off and
one of the issues are that
tens of thousands of people people have
been treated and the criticism has been
how could you be treating so many people
without knowing whether it works that is
the central criticism
uh and part of what is happening is no
one anticipated that the doctors will
embrace it
and it was embraced by patients and
doctors so
um what do we know about it we know that
there are
uh one randomized controlled trial that
was stopped in china because they did
not have enough patients
that that that showed efficacy in
improvement if you gave it before people
got sick
we know that there are a couple of other
randomized control trials that have also
been stopped
for a variety of reasons primarily
patient issues
uh um that again suggests efficacy
there are case series with controls what
that means is that in a hospital you
look at the people who are treated the
people they get treated and you compare
their mortality
not randomized not blinded subject to
bias
there are seven or eight of them showing
that
if you give it early you drop the
mortality significantly and aggregate
your drop mortality
by between 50 and 60 percent if you do
it before let me according to
so charles let me jump in here so who
are the patients what stage are they at
in the disease so this
is these are hospitalized patients
and when the problem has been that a lot
of the plasma has been used as salvage
therapy
antibody doesn't work at least ages but
the better results and these are all
in preprints and many of them have been
published already
is that if you treat early what is early
before people get intubated
the first couple of days that you head
off the deterioration that takes people
to the unit
and therefore you reduce mortality okay
and relative to
let's say dexamethasone with um okay
so dexamethasone is only useful at the
very end
okay it's useful in patients that are
already intubated when this severe is
associated
with improvements but no it hasn't been
shown to reduce mortality the only thing
that we have and i use the word
associated
with a reduced mortality is the early
use of plasma
so here we had a situation in the united
states now that we had
this enormous data set this and the
contract that the mayo clinic has been
running
this for the country and the question
become
can you look at that data set and get
some signals of evidence
and i'm happy to tell you that there are
two very strong signals of efficacy
one of them is that if you treat early
within the first three days of
hospitalization
the mortality is much lower than if you
treat later
again it's about 40 50 that's consistent
with everything we know
and the second one for those people who
think rigorously in terms of those
response
we have the first dose response data
that is that if you give people
uh plasma with high tider and plasma
with low tider
the likelihood of survival is better if
you got high tidal data
and that is being posted as a preprint
you can download it
and you can look at it and you can come
to your own conclusion so we have
reductions in mortality
from multiple countries iran iraq
china italy uh the united states
um reporting it we and we have this
database
what we don't have out and this is where
the controversy is
we don't have a large clinical trial
double blind telling you that
that when you break the seals that you
got efficacy they are ongoing
but we are not there yet and then the
question that
is what do you do with this information
do you allow its use
or do you wait till you get definitive
data and this
is when you get into now a conundrum uh
that is what you i think was some of the
premise of your question
yeah so so just keep it simple for a
moment we'll get into the
sort of political science if you will in
a moment but
what's the uh active and i assume the
active ingredient
in the plasma is neutralizing antibodies
but is there any evidence
that that's true uh the paper in the
in the preprint uh server has only total
antibody
and that was for a reason because the
test that we use
uh is easily available but i can tell
you that the data
we have data some of it is presented
that this correlates with neutralizing
antibody as to whether the mechanism is
neutralizing antibody we don't know
it may very well be that is antibody
dependent cellular cytotoxicity
or something else and that is just
traveling together
but that that is that is that data
exists
it's important obviously we'll come to
vaccines in a moment i guess but
um the correlates to protection are
obviously important for vaccine design
and so if if indeed even once you're
sick or infected uh neutralizing anybody
can rescue if i can use that word
uh then that's that's a strong
correlated protection as it were for
thinking about vaccine design absolutely
because for vaccines you're going to
need a fraction of the antibody
to protect the host you need a fraction
of the amount of antibody you need for
for treating them so if these people are
responding to a unit of plasma that has
a set amount of antibody
that has been given to a patient that is
going to be diluted by a huge amount
imagine if you can elicit that tighter
in a person i think
most immunologists would say there is a
high likelihood that that person is
going to be protected
yeah now you've you're heading up a
major effort in the u.s
around around this tell us a little bit
about what arturo casa de val has been
doing
so people give me too much credit and i
don't want it
okay uh you know the people who need the
credit here are the people who are
running the clinical trials
i mean we have two at hopkins for the
two pis you have the ones dealing with
the irb
recruiting patients bringing infected
patients to some places to to treat them
uh my efforts have been you know to to
try to bring together
these very diverse groups that range
from basic scientists to
clinicians and to try to steer the work
towards doing good science and good
medicine
uh so that we get an answer and i will
tell you that even though
i'm associated as a proponent i try to
maintain equipose
i try to maintain aquapos if you show me
a randomized clinical trial that has
no efficacy i will be the first to say
you
that's better data and it trumps
everything that we have
yeah i'm surprised you're using the word
trump in this context but that's another
another conversation
um so where did we go from here uh you
know just
as you know uh and maybe members of our
audience know
uh the fda yesterday or the day before
uh uh were convinced that there wasn't
enough uh
randomized controlled trials to approve
the use of convalescent plasma
and this was reinforced i guess by
comments or statements by francis
collins head of the nih
tony fauci head of niaid and david lane
who's head of
clinical research at niaad those are a
pretty
powerful triumvirate of uh spokespeople
so what what's your response to that and
so they're all my friends and uh and i
would agree with them that we
don't have the randomized controlled
trial the
data we like i will tell you that the
all we have is a newspaper article we
don't really know
what happened but if you read the
newspaper article
the fda decided that they had enough
data to issue an approval
and the newspaper article says that
there was pushback from the nih
to do the clinical trials that's what's
in there so
the fda did the analysis and
decided that there was enough data and
there was apparently again believing the
article that there was pushback and they
said well the data are not there
i think that this gets into a much
bigger issue
in which is the knowledge problem and
everyone on this call
probably has a different set at where
you get convinced
and what i would say is that in my mind
the way i approach it is today right we
don't have the control
trials yet but we have a lot of other
data
and we have at least established that
this stuff is safe it's not like you're
giving it to people and you're getting
reactions
and what is the thresh what is your
threshold for using
i think my own threshold is that what
we're having plays here in the united
states
it's fine we have the people can get it
through this contract with mayo call the
extended taxes protocol
and the people that feel that the
clinical trials need to be done
fine that let's let let work really hard
to get that data let's let's let's
do this time and bequeath to future
generations
really good epistemic evidence
that plasma works so when bird flu hits
us we don't get into this kind of debate
so i am totally uh supportive of that i
do think
that what i ask everybody is to become
familiar with the data and see where you
are
and it's okay if you believe that only
clinical trial data
if that is the case or you or you're
willing to settle for
for the fact that the plasma has worked
for example in the treatment of animals
it's in animal models multiple animal
models you take you
you can treat them but
but government in this case through the
his agency
of the fda has to decide to approve it
or not so
we all can decide as individuals but but
doesn't doesn't there need to be a sort
of a
a regulator i mean i think that that
that to me would be
a question for canada because here at
least in the united states you can get
it
you if you are in a hospital in the
united states okay
you one can get it one can get the
plasma i think that that question
there are many countries watching this
and trying to determine do we throw
support for plasma or not and they're
watching at the fda and they're watching
the situation and what i would say
is you know become aware of the data
you can be a scientist you can read it
the data are all out there
i'm aware that more goods data are
coming but at least there is
a lot of stuff in the public domain yeah
so this is they can get it because of
emergency
usage actually so what we have here in
the united
states is that that what the fda
gave the contract was given to the mayo
clinic the mayo clinic basically keeps
track of anybody who gets
plasma and this is where that data came
from that analysis
so a doctor basically has to go to the
website register a patient
and then agree to continue to provide
them it was a safety protocol
that no one ever anticipated would would
be associated with 70 000 patients
yeah and uh and that's where it is so
you can continue to get it here
and uh and let's try to continue to to
get the best data possible
so one of the questions in the from the
audience is how do you make sure that
the plasma doesn't contain
contain other pathogens that will induce
you know new diseases you know i'm
thinking of the
the the uh back in the 80s when
a lot of blood donations were
contaminated if you will with with hiv
a lot of people got hiv or not a lot but
some people so
i think that that is there is always a
small concern a small probability
that some individuals uh that that a
pathogen can get through
today uh the blood industry
in internationally is incredibly uh
careful they're tested against all known
passages
uh does it mean that can one get through
yeah but for example
you do certain things you don't pull
stuff
you use single units one of the problems
in the past
has been when you pull everything and
this is what happened in the 80s you
would often pull
many units that increases the likelihood
that you would
that you would cause uh you could hurt
more people
but i think the the safety of pla is is
is
at least the safety of a blood
transfusion which today
most people will agree is pretty safe at
least in the medical arena
i guess the one of the encouraging
things just to move off
the issue of what what's the robust
knowledge in this area for a moment
well one of the encouraging things about
the the data so far
is it suggests that indeed let's assume
it's
neutralizing antibodies to the virus
that's actually
uh efficacious here clinically
efficacious
it suggests that indeed the whole idea
of making a vaccine that will prepare
the host
if you will beforehand by inducing the
the
synthesis of neutralizing antibodies
will actually work
uh i don't know what your response is i
agree with you completely alan i mean
when we started there was a lot of
concerns i mean my inbox is full of
emails from eminent immunologists and
virologists
who were extremely concerned that we
were going to give
we were going to hurt people by giving
antibody dependent enhancement
this is a phenomenon known in the
coronaviruses whereas some
antibodies are able to drive the
the inflammation or devi or devi or the
viral replication
and hurt the host and in fact some of
the prior vaccines to coronavirus had
run into some of those issues
and one of the great things about the
plasma project is that the plasma
project delivers
to the vaccine world the knowledge that
these antibodies are safe
that we are not seeing for example
antibody dependent enhancement we are
not seeing cytokine storms
and and the plasma project is hopefully
will deliver to the vaccine world a
knowledge
of how much antibody do you really need
to affect therapy
because then you know that that will be
that's the standard that's a high
much more likely you will protect with
lower your protection i think the two
that you know whatever happens with
plasma plasma is going to make
major contributions to monoclonal
antibody development
and to vaccine development that are
obviously things that we're going to
need in the next
few months yeah i mean that's uh
pardon the pun but that bleeds into sort
of another area
which is of course monoclonals so
instead of using convalescent plasma
as the therapy as a drug the production
of monoclonal antibodies
presumably to the spike protein or some
peptide
of the spark protein protein maybe the
receptor binding domain of the spike
protein
so the question is whether the the
controversy around convalescent plasma
is going to evaporate arturo if we
actually get robust monoclonal
antibodies
that and and and we've been helped of
course by the experience with molecule
by the convalescent plasma
story that there's good reason to think
it would work
what's your what's your thoughts about
that actually so i spent my entire life
working on monoclonal antibodies and
this is where i
i i'm a believer obviously in a defined
product that one reaction one isotype
and you can put it together
my if you had asked if you had said to
me in march that we were having a
conversation in late august about plasma
i would have said alan by then we would
have moved away
i think that we plasma is nothing more
than a temporary stop gap before
gamma globulins come in or even the
monoclonal
rush and the fact is that uh that
they're not here they're just beginning
testing that and there was a newspaper
article here in the united states last
week
in the new york times so they're also
encountering tremendous delays
in doing the randomized clinical trials
so
um so i am a believer that it's going to
be
i believe her that the plasma issues
will be resolved by the time the
monoclonals are available
and that the and the resolution of the
plasma issues
will help the monoclonals uh go forward
because we do have
randomized control trials going on here
at hopkins
on the outpatient space in which uh
in which those are expected to be
completed in a couple of months
they could provide the information that
the
that the trial is the people who are
demanding that kind of thing
do it i i will tell the audience though
that a lot of what we know in medicine
and a lot of i never went through a
randomized controlled trial
antibiotics never want to randomize
controlled trials many of the types of
surgery that we do today
didn't go to randomized controlled trial
this is one
very pure way to get a knowledge
but there are other ways of knowledge
and i think
it's important all of us will engage in
this debate
to learn about the various ways in which
what i call the knowledge problem how do
you know what you know
yeah you know there's a famous story
which i'm sure you know
uh barry marshall in australia won the
nobel prize
for showing that antibiotics an
antibiotic would uh
cure him uh of his ulcer which a
bacteria-induced ulcer totally
transformed our thinking about ulcers
from being
stress induced to be bacterially induced
that was hardly he was both the placebo
and the control group
right if you will he drank this stuff
and gave focus
yeah and won the nobel prize for it so
yeah it's a perfect example
i think of what you just said but you
know what i find very interesting is the
cognitive dissonance
uh that we all have like we all have
we're human we basically
we do the best we can but for example if
you had had
a set of adverse effects that would have
been given
tremendous weight right
right that would have been and yet if
you basically report the opposite
that you're having good results well i
don't believe it until you give me more
and the quote and to me that is very
interesting
on how we for example the earliest
associations of hepatitis
with blood transfusions came from plasma
use
in the 1930s and 1940s and there were
anecdotes
yet those anecdotes led to the discovery
of the hepatitis viruses
people didn't sit there and said well
you know you didn't give a randomized
control trial
how do you know that they wouldn't have
turned yellow if they didn't get the
the plasma and this is the kind of
cognitive dissonance
that we live with and it's all right
we're human and and
that's right we're who we are i mean do
no harm i guess is the
right you know there's a story
maybe a transition to vaccines for a
second but but
in that transition it's related to
plasma convalescent plasma
this phenomenal story which i think
should give everybody
cause for optimism uh which is
this fishing boat went out to sea with
over a hundred
workers on the fishing boat and they all
got coveted 19. except for three of them
and they were the only three that had
antibodies to the virus
it was in a preprint amazing story
i mean i think it's remarkable this
experiment of nature as it were
happened and it certainly gives me great
optimism
that i'll overstate it to make a case a
little bit
that i think it's going to be easy to
make a vaccine
i agree this is not hiv this is not
influenza
this we are not dealing with a with
something that is immunologically very
uh very difficult i will tell you that
as soon as the boxing is available i'm
going to go and take it uh
because i believe based on everything
that i'm seeing that anything that
elicits neutralizing antibodies
yeah and certainly they publish the
published data from both the rna
vaccines
the protein subunit vaccine and the
adenovirus vector vaccines
so three very different platforms for
making
uh vaccines are all eliciting
neutralizing antibodies
both in experimental animals and
non-human primates
but also in humans and of course in
non-human primates where you can do the
experiment
it's also providing protective immunity
against a challenge
by the virus so these are very
encouraging results
uh i think uh as we go forward i agree
with you
i've been following the same story and
i'm very very encouraged
i think we're gonna have many vaccines
available but this time next year
yeah and i and i think a lot of us are
gonna be vaccinated i think that we
one of the issues that we're going to
face uh in the back scene
uh is the large numbers of
immunocompromised patients
uh that may not make a response to the
vaccine
and one of the things that we are
already learning
is that people some of these people have
been maintained by giving
multiple infusions of plasmid
when they are bone marrow suppressed or
something like that and we have to think
how we're going to deal with that
it also may be that the vaccines will be
very good at taking people who had
kobe 19 and giving them a boost a boost
uh in case that uh you know to really
think about eradicating this thing
i mean seniors of course will also
because of the fall off of the
robustness of the immune response may
also be at risk because they're also in
a sense immunocompromised
um and so there also it's some cause for
worry
i think if enough people take the
vaccine provided of course it's shown to
be safe and effective
and indeed we we just had a um i i had
to slip out of the vaccine task force
meeting where it's on right now as we
speak to have a chat with you but this
is much more fun
is is um this whole issue of vaccine
hesitancy
and what are the parameters that that
determine vaccine hesitancy and
certainly in canada
and i think it's a bit different country
to country but in canada it looks like
one of the major determinants of whether
people will accept a vaccine
provided it's been shown to be safe and
effective
is whether they trust it's it's trust in
a word
trust in government and government
spokespeople um and trust in
their caregiver and what their caregiver
says
uh so i think we're all crossing our
fingers that this
these vaccines will all turn out to be
safe and effective we will know after
the phase
three trials at least in a the time
period of those phase three trials
uh and that we'll be able to get the
vaccine as soon as possible in
probably in early 2021 but uh it's it's
a
it's an interesting time i think you
know this
this series is called science is the
exit strategy that you and i are
participating in
it's a phrase we i actually stole with
permission from
um jeremy farar who's head of the
welcome trust
um i think there's never been an example
of how important science is uh
to be the the phrase i'll steal from you
now
the beachhead of our defense against
this virus
i know i think it's quite remarkable how
important science is
and all of us you know whether we're
immunologists vaccinologists or
lay people now know all about
neutralizing antibodies and i think
it's wonderful you know to hear friends
who are not scientists
know all about this stuff and talk about
convalescent plasma talk about
safe and effective vaccines it's been
we've all had a science education
because of public 19. absolutely i mean
if you think back to
january or or february the scientific
establishment in most of the world
was illegal uh we
are facing reproducibility crisis facing
problems with retractions facing
uh funding issues and yet within a few
weeks
the scientific establishment is the
humanities line of defense against this
aircraft carriers tanks don't help you
uh this basically is denial it's
applicational knowledge
and in march first if you have gotten
sick and here in the united states i'm
sure in canada the only thing that we
would have had
better than in 1918 was a respirator on
oxygen
dial forward three or four months you
now have
dexamethasone you have this severe and
you have plasma in many places
yeah and this is and and this is the
beginning
of what's coming so the important thing
is to
listen to the health authorities stay
well
because you don't want to get this thing
it's too unpredictable
uh i think the future will be able to to
eradicate it yeah this is not a good
disease to get absolutely not right
it's not unpredictable okay
can i see you on the screen yeah also
questions you want us to uh
shield i might jump in yes so thank you
both so much for
for sharing your insights um but i did
promise to ask a few questions that have
come up through the through the q a
um so maybe maybe i'll start with a
simple question is it possible at this
moment to test to verify people have
antibodies
to test verify yeah yeah
i think it is i mean i think that we are
the antibody tests are getting better
and better
with every week and a lot of the false
positives are being
eliminated and i think that the answer
is yeah it should be possible to do that
yeah and certainly on a research basis
um uh there's no false
policy that there are negatives on a in
a research lab you can very definitively
show whether there's binding antibodies
and neutralizing antibodies which are
different and and it's important
um another question that that has come
in
relates to what we've been hearing more
about the so-called long covid
where people who return from hospitals
or indeed never went into hospitals in
the first place but have been had
have been dealing with um debilitating
symptoms for many months
will vaccines or plasma treatments be
effective for these individuals yeah so
i don't know
uh i suspect the the one thing that we
are learning about covet is
is how um how treacherous this thing is
that it appears to be a systemic
infection that is not only the lung that
it may be
affecting the brain the kidneys and a
couple of other things
if it was established and i i i
stressed the word if that these some of
this was the result of chronic infection
uh which we don't have any data for then
i can imagine
antivirals plasma monoclonals being able
uh to treat them forward if it turns out
to be
sequela of immunological damage i think
we're going to need very very different
types of therapies
it may be this equella of immunological
damage or maybe the sequela of
um of biological data damage that the
virus itself is
is uh damaging cells in the lung or in
the brain
uh so so these are these are important
questions and
issues but we don't have any answers to
that yet
um another question has come in asking
where are we
with respect to synthetic neutralizing
antibodies
they're in clinical trials i i assume
when you call synthetic you call
is what i call monoclonals because
they're made in the lab
so uh they're in clinical trials i think
that they're very promising
and if they can produce and here is the
big if
if they can be produced in sufficient
quantity to treat the people who need it
they will certainly replace plasma but i
will
caution that in the under uh resource
parts of the world
the only antibodies therapy is going to
be available is going to be plasma
because they will not be able to afford
a monoclonals
and gamma globulins are going to be
actually very very expensive
just to put a canadian slant on this if
i could kate for a moment
there's a company in vancouver abcella
that has received a lot of funding from
the canadian government to produce
monoclonals and i i know that their
their monoclonals regenerons in new york
and a few others
are showing very early promising results
in clinical trials
good news yeah it's very good news
um it's i mean it's different countries
have been uh i suppose putting efforts
into developing at home strategies
how there's sort of been talk of vaccine
nationalism
as well um i mean you both coming
at this issue from from different
geographic and political
places what are you what are your
thoughts on the likelihood of
of there being collaboration and and um
i suppose the distribution of vaccines
when something's developed in terms of
who will get treated first
so i'll jump in here look i think it's
um
a a huge fallacy to think that if we
let's say we could vaccinate every
canadian
with a vaccine and and not vaccinate
people in africa or only vaccinate 20
of people in africa or india or wherever
that were therefore protected uh because
i think one thing we should remember is
that
this global pandemic started by a virus
infecting a single individual
in wuhan china so the lesson from that
is that as long as there's one person
who's infected and
is infectious all of us are at risk
so if the pandemic is anywhere it's
everywhere
um and so vaccine nationalism is uh
buys you a kind of a false security that
you think you can
you can you know build an island you
know a moat around your country
and protect yourself and you only have
to look at what's happened in new
zealand
over the last few weeks they had no
cases for 102 days
but no country is an island literally
where all people are always going we're
trading nations
new zealand can't depend on its own
produce to
to survive uh somebody brought it in
and now there's i don't know the final
number but something like 19 or 25 cases
and of course since the virus grows
exponentially as it affects
two or three people that unless
something is done quickly
that little spark of a fire will quickly
spread and
you know into a forest fire so i
um i think vaccine nationalism in the
first instance gives you a false sense
of security but at the end of the day
it's not a solution we need to make sure
that
uh everybody on the planet has access to
a safe and effective
vaccine and or treatment i
second that completely we're all in this
together and
one of the nice things that has happened
in this epidemic is that up to now
there has been a tremendous amount of
sharing and working together people have
forgotten about credit people have
forgotten about all those things
and it's really really uh been the
the the the human scientific
establishment
rather than a national one has responded
in unison
um well maybe to extend that point a
little bit what are your thoughts on
russia's decision
to go ahead with the vaccine i think it
was a week ago or so that they announced
well i think that's unfortunate um i i
think uh you know going back to the
discussion we had
on convalescent plasma there's a
difference between a therapy
and a preventive vaccine with a therapy
you're talking about people who are ill
with a vaccine you're talking about
people who are healthy
so if you're going to give thousands of
people who are healthy
a drug or a molecule or a vaccine in
this case
you better be really sure that that
vaccine is safe and effective
otherwise you could get into a lot of
trouble
both ethically and public health-wise
and the second thing is if you're giving
a vaccine
or a computative vaccine to a group of
people
who are who are still healthy and
uninfected
how do you show that actually the
vaccine is
effective in preventing the disease
there's the statistics
gets really serious and it's interesting
to contrast that to what arturo said
about convalescent plasma actually
with convalescent plasma most people are
ill that's why they're getting
convalescent plasma
so you can follow them and see if they
get better well
if you give a healthy person the vaccine
and they don't get
the disease is that because of the
vaccine
or they've been religiously physically
distancing and washing their hands
etc etc the only way to do that is a
rigorous
randomized with a controlled trial
where you can really look at the data
and say yes that vaccine is safe and yes
it was effective in preventing disease
so i think it's very unfortunate that
russia
is experimenting on their own population
i mean i i agree with alan that safety
with anything that you're going to use
prophylactically safety
is has to be assured
with the vaccines that seem to be
emerging as strong candidates do we know
very much in terms of what the
expected protection will be will the
like will the
um protection last for several months
are we looking at years do we know how
many doses will be needed
that's a great question um i think the
the answer is we don't know
we won't know both how many what the
percent of people who will be protected
remember the seasonal flu vaccine has
never been a hundred percent
effective in terms of protecting
everybody so we don't know with a
with covet 19 vaccine assuming we can
make one
whether it'll be a 70 percent protective
ninety percent
and we also don't know how long it will
last what the securability of the
vaccine will be
and we also don't know whether the
durability will will vary
with the population group will it be
different with seniors for example
versus younger people people with
hypertension people with diabetes
um or or who are immunocompromised as
arturo said earlier
for some other reason so we'll just have
to wait and see
but i think what we can hope is that if
the vaccine is
let's say more than 60 or 70 70
protective for a reasonable period of
time
that hurt immunity along with physical
distancing and washing our hands
will stop this virus we don't need 100
protection with the vaccine to stop the
virus
i mean i would have to add that you know
i'm an optimist that
maybe this we may still be able to
eradicate this thing
if there is national international
cooperation uh the
issue would become only if the
coronavirus becomes established
in in another animal and then begins to
circulate
uh back and forth so that would be
anything but right now
i'm being optimistic that we're gonna
make a back scene that's gonna work by
multiple mechanisms
and uh we're gonna we're gonna burn this
thing out
well um that's about all the time that
we have for today
thank you both so much uh for sharing
your insights with us and thank you to
everyone who's been joining us from home
um i invite everyone to visit our
website at cfar.ca to find out more
about these series
and to view a recording of this talk
which should be posted
early next week uh so on behalf of
seafarer thank you both so much
thank you very much for thank you i
really enjoyed our our conversation this
afternoon
we should have a glass of wine that
would have made it oh man the other
things that would have
we would have said that we didn't
thanks everybody
you